speaking of NTR I guess we're just let's
just continue the NTR train because I
had to recommend an NTR I actually
enjoyed okay and I recommended them uh
what's the name again there's all
Zuma which means NTR wife yeah so
so I I remember okay hold up all right
okay okay why did you choose this one
okay okay so for the record I [__]
despise NTR I die yeah I think I think I
think we all despise NTR yeah right and
I remember the first time I saw this I
was like the name has Network in the
name yeah there is no [__]
possibility this can end well I'm
surprised you even clicked play with the
time
yeah but
the reason I the the reason this is the
closest thing I've come to an NTR
what the reason why this is the closest
thing I've found to an NTR I enjoy is
because I was [__] happy that this
dude got empty yard right
this dude this dude
pissed me the [__] off like the dude
that gets empty yard actually like
pissed me off do you want to explain the
problem okay so the premise is okay so
there is
there is a main guy the main girl
obviously and they're a married couple
and the dude is an idol fan right
Richard that's right yeah yeah yeah the
dude is an idol fan and he is obsessed
with this one Idol right he is so
obsessed that he he found his wife
because his wife reminds him of this one
item like they're identical yeah they're
they're almost identical looking so
[__] up and when they're having and
when they're having sex he doesn't refer
to his wife by his wife's name he refers
to her as his Idol's name his favorite
Idol's name role play yeah manager and
like producer
yeah essentially he's incapable of
getting hard unless she role plays as
his favorite Idol yeah right and I'm
like that's [__] up what a [__] that
[__] I'm I remember seeing that I'm like
she deserves better and of course one
day his like one of his one of his
friends comes over and she explains the
situation that she's in yeah and if and
of course he's like well if you want to
if you want if you want a man to treat
you right I'm right here it's the first
time I've ever seen an NTR and I'm like
wow the guy in tring has the right
opinion no yeah wait he's like where
he's like no because at the beginning
when she's like yeah so my husband and I
do this thing when we have intercourse
and he's like wow that's [__] up and
I'm like you know what kind of agree
yeah I mean I think that everyone is
[__] up in this in this show yeah of
course it uh the wife probably uh
I mean she should have left him straight
up oh yeah oh yeah I'm sorry but like
did you really marry the guy who was
only into you because you look like like
I I feel like that's a little bit on you
I'm like how did you not did you not
think about that before you sign those
like you know marriage papers like yeah
obviously we're looking way too much
into this yeah um and I am because we're
reviewing it yes
um but it man man it was bad yeah yeah
like there's there's uh
the fact that it had to be his like
friend like his his his childhood friend
who comes over and this dude is clearly
a scumbag yeah of course she has the
scumbag they give him the traditional
anime
and the tanned skin and blonde hair yeah
which is tradition if there are two
things that speak NTR
ugly bastard and tanned blonde hair [__]
I don't know [__] the [__] boy yeah
right I don't know why I don't know why
it's just like this is you do the Idol
guy this is your childhood friend this
guy yeah that's what I was questioning
I'm like how did you guys become friends
like is he like a formal Idol fan or
like did you just see him on the street
so like what like what is the connection
yeah and then and then so yeah like
obviously uh the they're having uh
dinner together and the main guy uh the
husband passes out yes as he does as he
does because he's like drunk yeah and
then uh they start talking the the wife
and the friend yeah and obviously they
explain and obviously he's like bro what
the [__] I'm instead of just having it
as bro what the [__] he's like bro what
the [__] let me get in on that I mean
let me show you I have a radical
solution
I like and so they just start doing it
and it's like okay I mean I guess but
they stopped doing it in front of him
sleeping and then that's one thing I've
never understood about like not just NTR
hentai but like even NTR like javs yeah
right because that's such a common
situation it's also normal important
like yeah obsession with people sleeping
I don't know I think it's the Forbidden
aspect of it but why does it have to be
that and I'm like how are you not waking
up that's what okay of course there are
there are I get the chlorophyll thing
but like you know which sometimes
happens
you know when you get chloroform then
you just like knock the [__] out but
it's like I never thought I'd hear that
out of course I get the chloroform thing
what's that sleeping thing that's a bit
too funny how deep can your sleep be
where where your wife is getting rare
failed literally centimeters from your
face and you're just like well no no
he's sweet dreams this dude is railing
her so hard that her you know her
um I don't know how to describe it
juices are going on his face and he's
not waking up yeah exactly yeah and I
was like am I supposed to be turned on
by this because I'm just suspending
every disbelief that this guy is asleep
yeah yeah I mean I'm screaming monitor
like work out wake up you know I it
would have been so much more fun no I
kind of wish he woke up I would have
been so much better you know because
like I I'm this is the reason I
recommended this was because this is the
one NTR that unfortunately doesn't have
an episode too and I wanted this to
happen episode two because you know what
I'm I watch this and I'm like they did
not go far enough I need to [__] off I
need to see this [__] guy in tears
crying okay okay they did not go far
enough I agree he sucks but I don't
think he deserves that
I feel this show is like in the five
stages of grief we're still in the
denial phase
you know he doesn't deserve the wife but
I don't think he deserves to have his
whole life shattered in front of him
I
you know that's that's something else do
you know what you know what he's an idol
fan
all right any day we can make an idol
Fan's life I feel better I'm joking I'm
joking I guess yeah seriously don't do
that when you put it like Dad I mean no
just I just the dialogue was weird like
they were having a full-on conversation
while going at it yeah and she's like we
should we should become sex friends and
it's like what and he's like okay dude
just break up with yourself my favorite
my favorite thing about it is like at
the end when like when it finishes and
then there's that final scene of the
husband you know doing the same thing to
the wife right but this time the wife is
like all I have to do is build up my
frustration and I'll be able to release
it I'm like what is this like this is
like the Pokemon move bide you know
where you just like wait five times
like that's not how that works why why
you what are you what are you getting
from this just get out of this goddamn
message get the divorce papers bro I
mean I agree she should never have ended
up with this guy in the first place but
you know as as the married man here I'd
be like you know if I did that to Sydney
[__] like I I don't deserve Sydney you
know like like we know you aren't you
doing that though she looks like the
anime character what's that one Marion
yeah isn't he just doing that with
Marion uh excuse me we've been dating
for eight years actually
I just I'm just like I don't know why
you would want to be with a girl if if
you want to be with a girl just because
she reminds you of someone else you're a
[__] beta man you you deserve you
deserve bad things to happen to you and
you know what I like I watched this and
I was like I'm [__] happy the ntr's
happening in fact they're not going far
enough this guy should have woken up he
should have got his dream shot I believe
he should have woken up yeah because I
think the ensuing plot would have been
more exciting oh yeah because I I feel
like what was I feel like really
disappointed because they obviously set
themselves up for an episode too they
obviously set themselves up for a sequel
where they like mind break this guy yeah
mind break mind break this [__] beta
and then they didn't do it and then they
didn't do it I'm like this is the one
time I've actually wanted a sequel to an
NTR and you don't give it to me you
don't give it to me go on guys do people
like mind break
oh
that's why do people like my question
why do people like Minecraft why do
people want to see a man like just an
entire world no no my mind break I think
goes like both ways so there's like you
know when the girl has a mind break
where like the sex is so good it like
breaks their minds yeah and then like
and I I mean I used the wrong
terminology but there's just like NTR
where you just like it's not that's
that's not mind break that's just
depression yeah that's just like [__]
ruin someone's life that's just that's
just yeah
there's a difference between mind break
and mental break
bro I need a [__] mental break after
watching half these shows
it was so bad it was true I I was just
painful watching it it was so boring
yeah so [__]